[Music]
good morning Hank it's Friday January
12th if you're wondering why I'm
drinking a beer in the morning it's
because it's 12:15 in the morning I have
to get up early tomorrow so I'm doing
the vlog tonight if you're wondering why
I'm drinking Light beer instead of
regular beer it's because I'm doing
Weight Watchers
I don't like Weight Watchers I'm tired
of eating popcorn they don't give you
enough points I need more points this
video blog post is going to consist
entirely of ideas misprinted business
card utilization ideas if you had a hole
punch a lot of patience and a lot of
dental floss you could make Katherine a
dress you could eat them while
discussing the political situation in
Kenya since you just got married you can
use them to write very terse thank-you
notes in very small handwriting you
could wallpaper every room in your
dollhouse everybody thinks you have a
dollhouse now
punishment ideas I'm just going to pick
punishment ideas from things that are
currently in our living room several of
our books would make excellent
punishments this is the continuum
history of apocalypticism it's 1100
pages long it's pretty punishing the
person who fails to update has to send
out a Christmas card next year and the
Christmas card has to include the
picture of a baby someone else's baby
maybe Emmitt clouds baby the person who
fails to update has to knit a scarf that
would suck the person who fails to
update has to eat one styrofoam peanut
and finally don't you think it would be
a good punishment if you had to do your
happy dance for three minutes and 30
seconds but you could only do it at 5
second clips at a time so you had to
have a total of jeez it's too late to
call Daniel hold on 70
I think 70 dances in 70 different
locations I'd be pretty good punishment
or maybe that should be a project look
at intersperse our happy dances you do
35 I do 35 that has some appeal for me
any
triste